so as i say the democratic media complex
they created this and they are liars and
they will maintain the lie just because
kyle writtenhouse is acquitted today as
he should have been legally and morally
does not mean that these bastards won't
continue to lie to you and lie about you
and lie about the country and lie about
the state of play
now earlier i said that joe biden had
come out and he had said that he didn't
watch the trial and so he really had no
opinion and the jury had done his job
that's what joe biden said now he's
released his statement it's amazing the
man can't do anything right for more
than 22 seconds before ron klain steers
him wrong again he just released a
statement did our
not all their president quote well the
verdict in kenosha will leave many
americans feeling angry and concerned
myself included we must acknowledge that
the jury has spoken
why are you angry and concerned was it
because you slandered kyle rittenhouse
as white supremacist in your campaign ad
are you angry and concerned because you
might sue your ass for defamation as you
probably should
why are you angry and concerned sir what
do you know about this trial that we
don't
they are liars and they will rewrite
history to make the lie stick
this is why they keep trotting out
michael brown as though he was an
innocent or jacob blake as though he was
an innocent
because all that matters is the
narrative they will continue to lie and
lie and lie do not pay attention to them
get better news sources and tell all
your friends to do the same
here let me just give you this here's
yahoo news's description this is post
acquittal okay post acquittal here is
their description of what happened to
written house quote
written house was 17 when he carried an
ar style semi-automatic rifle on the
streets of kenosha during a turbulent
protest against racial injustice in the
summer of 2020 and opened fire on
demonstrators killing joseph rosenbaum
and anthony huber and seriously wounding
gage gross crudes
okay that is the least accurate
description of what happened i have ever
seen
according to yahoo news after the trial
after the video after drone footage
after witness testimony after physical
evidence
after that their description of this was
not kyle rittenhouse went to kenosha in
the middle of riots to defend private
property he was accosted by a convicted
child molester and chased he turned
around and shot that man when he lunged
for the gun then he was chased by a mob
who was trying to kill him and he shot
two other people killing one that would
be an accurate depiction of what
happened according to yahoo news
he just arrived during a turbulent
protest and then opened fire on
demonstrators just randomly spraying
them with bullets apparently
these liars they are liars
they lie to you
and if this were you they would lie
about you
because they don't care how many eggs
they have to break in order to make the
omelet they do not care if you are if
you are an obstacle to their utopian
vision of what america should be like
they will break you they will destroy
you
they would have gladly sent a 17 year
old kid to prison for the rest of his
life for an act of self-defense and they
are weeping today because
kyle rittenhouse isn't going to spend
the rest of his life behind bars for a
crime he never committed and didn't
commit on video
here was cnn today decrying the legal
process oh well you know the problem
with the legal process says cnn is that
you know really the law is just
favorable to the defendant
the law in wisconsin is very favorable
to a defendant claiming self-defense the
prosecution has to affirmatively
disprove self-defense beyond a
reasonable doubt if the jury went back
there and had some reasonable doubt then
they were to return a not guilty verdict
and that it appears is what they've done
well you know the the law of self by the
way can i explain something the law of
self defense is a key element of every
legal regime ever in human history if
there's a legal regime it includes the
law of self defense that is the only law
that mattered here
this is not because the law was
favorable to the defense it's because
the defendant didn't commit a crime they
all know this but they're going to lie
they're going to pretend that he got off
on a technicality he did not get off on
a technicality kyle written house he got
off because he never should have been
indicted in the first place and only
because the prosecutor is a despicable
lying hack was this ever brought
by the way this speaks to a broader fact
which is that republicans conservatives
freedom-minded people need to start
electing da's who aren't
outgrowths of a progressive legal
thinking system that believes that you
should indict people for no reason so
long as they fit the check marks that
you need for your narrative
it wasn't just that guy on cnn got bob
bianchi former head prosecutor from new
jersey morris county new jersey on cnn
saying you know innocence well yeah it's
a mistaken belief
it's not about narratives it's
unfortunate that narratives there's a
tale of the wagon the dog here it's the
facts that came out there in the course
of the case that showed that those
narratives were in large part completely
inaccurate and so this jury did its job
by looking at the facts taking its time
deliberating over the evidence and even
though it may have been a mistaken
belief they believe kyle rittenhouse
under those circumstances felt not only
death but great bodily harm a lot of
people are missing that
mistaken belief where's the mistaken
belief coming from he's doing well until
he gets to mistaken believe okay this
isn't the worst of the worst okay
there's not even close to the worst of
the worst you got msnbc
all of their guests doing the same thing
eugene robinson says this is vindication
of vigilantism weird because what it
seems like more is a vindication of the
fact that if a child molester tries to
grab your gun you can shoot him
or the vindication of the fact that if a
man approaches you with a pistol to
shoot you you're allowed to shoot him in
the bicep or the fact that if somebody
tries to smack you in the face with a
skateboard repeatedly you can shoot him
that doesn't sound super a lot like
vigilantism
you know it's so there are unique things
about this case but i what concerns me
though is that the result will be seen
as a vindication of vigilantism
of what kyle rittenhouse was doing the
larger context of what he was doing uh
you know during these demonstrations
over the shooting of of jacob blake
you got ben rhodes doing the same
routine the former hack writer turned
foreign policy adviser he says quote a
very dark message sent to all the other
heavily armed would-be vigilantes out
there oh it's about vigilantism now
well you know what for most of them it's
about race they're still trying to turn
this into a race case every person kyle
written how shot was white cal
rittenhouse is white there are no black
people involved in this case period none
it does not matter you know it's
trending on twitter today black lives
matter black lives matter was trending
on twitter this case does not include a
single black human
not one it does not matter
it has to fit the narrative
which is why you have for example
celeste ing who is the writer of little
fires everywhere tweeting out so
basically it's cool to just have an
ar-15 and go out and hunt black people
as long as you're white
the people he shot weren't even black
the what are you talking about doesn't
matter
stephen king
quote so the white guy goes free is that
the message
no the message is that the white guy can
defend himself just like anybody else
hey you have nicole hannah jones
remember nicole hannah jones is seen as
a real intellectual by the left
i don't know what to make of that
i honestly don't know
whether that means that the left is just
so unbelievably stupid like with the
brain power of an earthworm
that that to them she looks brilliant or
they're just patronizing her by
pretending that she's smart because
nicole hannah jones has never said a
true thing as far as i'm aware
it was just last week when she claimed
that we dropped the a bomb on hiroshima
and nagasaki because of the sunk cost
fallacy because we wanted to prove that
we'd spent our money wisely
on the manhattan project i mean she's
she's a complete fool from beginning to
end so here's what this complete fool
had to tweet quote
in this country you can even kill white
people and get away with it if those
white people are fighting for black
lives this is the legacy of 1619.
so just to get this straight a white man
shooting a white child molester and a
white criminal and a white person trying
to kill him is the legacy of 1619. 19.
weird
weird take by nicole hannah jones by the
way she then followed up that tweet by
suggesting that he cross state lines
with a gun which didn't even do
because she doesn't know what the hell
she's talking about because she doesn't
care what she's talking about because
the facts do not matter they don't
matter
here's joy reid the bloviating bag of
stupid over on msnbc quote we knew but
it's sometimes helpful to remind
ourselves how america was designed to
work it continues to work as design we
have learned again what is considered
legal for some people to do in america
it's helpful to know where you stand in
your country be safe out there
what what's it's
self-defense is legal for everyone joy
for everyone
but she says only some people only some
people will be acquitted under these
circumstances weird because at the
beginning of october
the city of chicago literally refused to
prosecute a case
in which
uh two members of gangs were shooting at
each other one person died and two
suspects were wounded and the city of
chicago was like we're not even going to
prosecute them
everyone involved was a person of color
okay like i don't know the hell she's
talking about what she thinks she's
talking about but this passes for wisdom
in left-wing circles
she also put out a blog post not not the
old blog post where she uh ripped on gay
people a new blog post it says kyle
rittenhouse trial was designed to
protect white conservatives who kill
nailed it meanwhile leticia james who
wants to run for governor of new york
after kneecapping andrew cuomo she
tweeted out this is a dark day for our
justice system as a lawyer i respect
jury verdicts but this is yet another
reminder that our system needs to be
uprooted and reformed
so you don't respect jury verdict
you just want to destroy the system
these folks are they're rewriting
history and i promise you three years
from now
the left will still be saying that kyle
written house is a white supremacist
murderer they will still be citing the
name of joseph rosenbaum as some sort of
martyr to the cause of black lives
even though he's the only person in the
entire situation who did anything that
had to do with race by the way what do
you have to do with race that night he
shouted the n-word
but he was the guy defending black lives
cory bush a liar who suggested that when
she was marching in ferguson missouri
white people were camped out on a hill
nearby shooting at her which is a
complete lie fabrication made up top to
bottom she tweeted out the judge the
jury the defendant it's white supremacy
in action this system isn't built to
hold white supremacists accountable
that's why black and brown folks are
brutalized and put in cages while white
supremacist murderers walk free i'm hurt
i'm angry i'm heartbroken
the narrative demands that this be about
the subjugation of black people
there are no black people involved so
they will just ignore that and just go
right for it anyway
it's incredible by the way i hope kyle
rittenhouse sues these sues these
jackasses into the ground i hope that he
covington catholics these people into
bankruptcy i hope that kyle rittenhouse
has a house made of money when all this
is over
i hope that kyle rittenhouse
is sitting atop a pile of cash because
of these people
just because they are liars and they
deserve it
bill de blasio the commie groundhog
murderer from new york he tweeted out
anthony huber and joseph rosenbaum are
victims they should be alive today
they're victims you see
anthony huber
who was convicted of assaulting his
brother and mother and joseph rosenbaum
convicted child molester both of whom
attempted to murder a 17 year old
they're victims according to mayor bill
de blasio that's not a surprise he is
kind of friendly with some
terrorist groups he says they should be
alive today the only reason they're not
is because a violent dangerous man chose
to take a gun across state lines and
start shooting people to call this a
miscarriage of justice is an
understatement it's a lie it's all
entirely a lie and they know it's a lie
and they don't care they don't this is
the part that's so mind-boggling just if
you're a moral human being you should
care at least a little about the truth
of particular fact patterns they don't
care at all
it's not like we don't have video of
this stuff
we have video of kyle rittenhouse that
night before any of the shootings take
place explaining why he was there this
is clip 22. here's kyle rittenhouse that
night explaining why he was there does
this sound like a young man who's
looking to murder people
does this sound like a young man who is
looking to come to kenosha and just
start strafing people with bullets
people are getting injured
and our job is to protect this business
and part of my job is to also help
people if there's somebody hurt i'm
running into harm's way that's why i
have my rifle because i need to protect
myself obviously i also have my med kit
we're protecting from the citizens and i
just got pepper sprayed by a person in
the crowd
so you had non-lethal but you just
respond we don't have non-lethal
so you guys are full and ready to defend
the property
yes we are okay now if i can ask can you
guys step back medical ems right here
okay and then at the end of the video
he's called off to do some medical help
for one of the people who's writing
sounds like a guy who's just out there
to murder people
adriano espaiot who's a representative
from new york congressman he said kyle
rittenhouse is living proof that white
tears can still forestall justice a
murderer is once again walking free
today our system is terribly broken why
because kyle rittenhouse cried he had
the temerity to cry in court white tears
they're just reading from the hymnal of
robin d'angelo white tears are bad
because white tears illicit emotional
responses in white juries and this is
just another example of black people
being subjugated you know the pretzels
they have to twist themselves in to
stick their heads this far up their own
asses
honest to god joe biden and other
democrats who think like he does about
these particular issues i have to wonder
why they even had to perform a
colonoscopy couldn't joe biden just see
in there
apparently all the democrats can
gavin newsom
the androgynous human kendall
governor of california he tweeted
america today you can break the law
carry around weapons built for a
military shoot and kill people and get
away with it
that's the message we've just sent to
armed vigilantes across the nation
is it no
is that the message that we sent because
the message that you guys kept sending
is that riots were good property
destruction was good
hell attempting to murder a 17 year old
was good all of that was good that made
you a hero it made you a person worthy
of emulation and defense
they are rewriting reality in real time
and if you're not mad about it you've
got to get mad about it it's important
to be mad about it it's important
because you need to tell everyone you
know that these people are liars and
they cannot be trusted because if they
lie about this they lie about everything
and they do
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed